your big kid you big kid I'm looking at
you right now dude I'm [ __ ] yeah what
are you doing tonight me lifting weights
but your arms are I can always tell when
you put on I got telling your 265 270
270 knots 40 mm should I throw - Shh -
say you're your 265 and I always know
about - I'm - Shh I'm not I shoulda got
him that relaxed all right what the [ __ ]
is calling this [ __ ] come from because
I walked by that pretty girl last night
and she goes yes so your body here your
arms are very big really you I worked
out right before this you need to be
hold on hey you're totally loved what's
up girl are you are you spotted by a
king at night snacking you know what a
candy you know what fat you just look I
like that kick I know three C's thick
yeah you don't look fat I'll do that a
bunch of people reach out to me with
Samantha for Oh brought me to so many
people I don't know who to go with my
boy Kevin I got so many friends we'll
call him up dude I got anavar I take it
what do you need and they're giving me
the run at something else it is
specialist yeah yeah it doesn't have
liver toxicity I got so many people hit
me up on valuable I also don't want to
shut down my nuts
it won't anavar you could do anavar
animal would shred you up you know where
you lose weight for whatever reason -
how many weight tell me Tony fat and
it's got very little houses in it why
not do well here's the thing you've got
to be a little careful to do it so it
has a tendency if you do too much of it
or whatever to bring your good
cholesterol down and your high good bad
cholesterol up so you have to be careful
with that but as long as you take like
in moderation
then someone sent me a link - they sent
me a link that you know hey this where I
get off of you're good I've used it a
thousand times the best part if you get
stopped by customs they resent it
well now you can you're an hour late
dude and daddy's got a doctor no I don't
[ __ ] doctors we can go to the doctor and
that I wash my hands now I just want to
just ship them and of our to the house
I don't want anavar I don't want
something that's gonna make me more
shredded I want something that puts on
about 10 pounds of muscle man a Houston
industrial objective take it easy with
the deca dude I can't do that do good I
wanted to test out but my fog and they
can kind of walk in diamond and you know
daddy's were
that daddy's gonna [ __ ] with attentive
Christians I got the genetics so I worry
that if I do it I could use a little
more energy though I feel like I should
just take a rough stab at it I'd love to
see you do it it's only two pills a
[ __ ] day or one pill a day really yes
it's a pill small pill big deal you work
out anyway what are you waiting talk to
me in the steroids right now I don't
know I feel like I'd want to put my own
ass yeah I'm on steroids I've you know
what I mean I gotta cut off that but
that's my problem too is I don't want to
be the 52 year old who's doing anavar
see that guy's kind of cool and to get
too big in your skin gets all Brown can
bring your blood pressure up a little
bit only if you're prone to it blood
pressure's conspiracy three and came
back the sex drives for both male and
female I got very blah so all right [ __ ]
sex you know yeah I'm gonna age down
it's like four minutes I'm not safest
gentle anabolic steroid which is
intended easily and taller about
children and women however it affects
the testosterone production in the human
body that might interfere with the
sexual production most of the people
will stack them with the testosterone
for avoiding the problems of other
supplements were designed to restoring
sex drive now I just want a nice subtle
anavar get a little shred city see how
my life goes what do you think class one
steroid I think it's good move if you do
it we should document it though is it
good if everybody knows or Drive well
you [ __ ] Batman one day it was like
what the [ __ ] I'm like what what
happened Oh that'd be funny we have
three episodes and then the fourth one
you're just jacked just shredded I
wouldn't mind doing it I would like to
do Oh click advanced search if I have
just five maybe seven pounds of muscle
on me it looks good like you know I just
it goes through my ass goes to my can I
be honest I look the same no matter what
I do whether I diet real hard
are you fine but I always look to say
you're a good-looking guy so you don't
don't worry about it yeah I know but I
never even even like when I was 230 kind
of like the same yeah I like I don't
think you look bad when you're this
heavy no but leave it even if it when
I'm dying super strict my face gets a
little leaner but look pretty much the
same I'm telling myself I agree I've
always said that I was looking exactly
this they're always on some kind of a
diet I'm always like a lot of [ __ ] just
be bigger and stronger than ever
in the room who gives a [ __ ] he doesn't
it's not gonna be all well Brendan if
anything is a comic you should be just
giant why wouldn't you be giant you have
this weird thing that comics are all
skinny or small that's [ __ ] just be
a big be the biggest strongest comic in
the world no that's not me the second
I'll be there I'll not be the second
toughest top well now you're what's
toughness of do my haters so heavy right
now yes dude you be the Robin - I'm
Batman your of it okay that's fine let's
do the Batman and Robin tour but let's
do the end of our tour tour these guys
are [ __ ] shredded
these guys are shred it smell like
protein oh and there's skin I want veins
they smell like beef jerky [ __ ] whey
protein I will do anavar for a little I
think I'm gonna go I think I'm gonna do
it I don't tell you so many black guys
gonna hook me up with this really
special doctor I'm gonna go do you might
do my blood work and then see what's
what is he in LA oh I just want the
whole I don't week process I want it now
I want it inst it I would be taking it
and then you ready me or may not be
Stallone's doctor I don't want to look
like Stallone no I know hurry look like
you well you I've always here's the
thing with you you've always wanted to
be a little bit more lean well yeah okay
it's the one thing that you'll never
truly be happy like I'll never truly be
happy because I'm not I'm not a Spanish
dancer who looks like Frank Grillo you
wouldn't no never you wish you were
bigger yeah you'll never be happy - you
are [ __ ] good actually I mean I mean
how old is he
seven thirty looks amazing let's be real
I mean Jesus Christ he's doing
everything that doesn't look that great
though no 73 I was just guessing he's
everything no no no he's he's in the 70s
he looks pretty [ __ ] good man I would
say so
dude he looks amazing I agree have you
seen his daughter oh she went to school
with me oh yeah was she cool I didn't
really know her I saw her around the
campus but she wears pajama to USC I
think his uh both of his daughters go to
USC now they are they are near over here
even they love their dad and he loves
them he's got great dad he gets along
he's got a great sense of humor Sloan's
just got a great sense of humor it
really does look at his wife she's 10
she's like Elizabeth her she's a [ __ ]
tent no stones a [ __ ] legend dude
he's a legend you're married to alleged
all girls ah
he's all those girl looks like a cat
Persian cat there whatever I love it I
love the Stallone dude dude you don't
think why don't we get him on the
podcast didn't talk about deccan anavar
dude what it feels like listen this is
what you got to do well don't be on all
the gear and look like the [ __ ]
morons out there that's the problem
he's on water in his face that's what
daddy can't have I can't have water
that's not fun can't have water and
that's not fun no matter what you do
time is getting to get to you his
daughters are just delicious young very
hook too young so creepy coming from me
I can't - well one's older though wait
they're all legal with one the Middle's
young I like to - I like the ones far
let are all dolls but but I'm Stallone
yeah well I don't take that picture
though okay I don't know what my
hesitation with steroids for Bryan
Callen is that then I'm that guy
now you know again you it's just not you
a dude who's a little too muscular but
I'm never gonna be 73 you not I mean
will you if you got straight-up like Roy
droids no dude you'd be I don't want
veins I I'd like to put a little way to
ruin you I'd like more of what you have
which is a little more thickness
I'd like what you have right so that's
that's why you need to be on anavar I
need to be on [ __ ] Taz nice I feel
like you just need to eat Oh hmm my
Trent my boy uh who is that guy I don't
want to be that who is that weirdo no my
boy what's his name
Nick Nick flower always says that he
goes you gotta eat
he got mad at me yesterday he goes you
need to eat I was like all right yeah I
don't know well I don't want to look
like that well that's that's the great
Jay case no he's an amazing actor he got
jacked
yeah old big like older due to her rip
I think it looks kind of cool yeah I
again yeah you gotta get in shape you
know you know why I just wanted leave
some LPS because the the new baby boys
come in end of November so you take
those pictures those kids can have those
pictures for everything you look at
those pictures can't be thinking that
dude
well I'll be like well Papa was yeah but
you can you know you want yeah I gotta
look better for that I don't know you
have the weirdest body dysmorphia I
don't understand it
like I I don't understand why you
wouldn't want to be just a bit just a
[ __ ] GI it doesn't beat everybody up
I don't want to beat everybody up well
you can and you should you should you
should bully people a little more I want
a little more bullying you I want a
little more bullying yo maybe the anavar
do it though yeah I want a ynm are
having some roid rage I want you walking
around and I want you just to shove some
people out of the way here periodically
you know what I mean
and then I want you to go to Chris
D'Elia I want you to go cuz you got in
his face last night which was good I
like the way you got in his face you got
up in his face last night I got a post
that picture of you trying to attack him
die say yeah these four great pictures
okay cuz he's trying he's gonna I'm
trying to hit him it's so funny
yep and then but you just won spending
last night man yeah I was great the
whole crew came out chin came out with a
lady
why do you don't shrug like that well
she was a bonafide
l8n wow did you see your antenna ah dude
she beautiful girl fine you don't say oh
no I went what are you doing shin
beautiful women always hanging out with
gay men but what did you find her
what'd she find her right she was like a
either did you threaten to kill her
right no I met her like freakin years
ago through someone just introduced us
and then like years later we hung out
once and then years later after that we
hung out yesterday and you actually said
hey my boys are doing the show you want
to come yeah well she said she wants to
do a solid me so that's how she's a
senior she's a piano player what else
does she do
can I see a picture she's a real estate
agent she's a really her name though I
don't want to get on say her name she's
a real estate agent a she's a real
estate she was actually bummed that I
didn't
you or anyone that I know about how this
is my boy I'm looking another house girl
why are you
yeah maybe our properties um that's a
terrible thing close that's s hold wait
you see it well go back that was that so
no look at oh it is you guys old
well that's I'm young they made Brian
real young that's look at how Chris
looks like Kaka in that what the [ __ ] is
that my face looks like straight-up nuts
dude I'm tight Felix just normal Felix
like George Bush and then [ __ ] Chris
looks awful look at my arms dude big I
worked out twice that's such fun I
pissed and it did worked out lifted
weights back to Chin's girl dude it's
not my girl
no then back to the girl that you know
in the you held hostage come to the past
murder yeah that's her ethnicity we what
do you think Korean girl she's headed
wow dude oh I can't for sure I've seen
those porn a chingar up a little we're
not show the fans this alright her in
the red with the splitter mm-hm and she
plays I'm warning man take my [ __ ]
money
oh no I'll buy whatever you want
let's just this [ __ ] butt out dead
you can quit right now is that room in
this house for my joke just roll my
sushi rolls what that takes you is
digging you guys to what we say you
[ __ ] first show that will grind in
me yeah
well both you guys but then we're you
actually walked by me I was like II
Brian and you just walk right big time
you yeah see I'd never I give her a hug
oh I didn't know where you were I know
it's dark was after the first show the
first show was a good show I whisper
because I went oh wow you were Chinchin
wait I was Brown went be safe and then
she's like I know she went help uh-huh
I think I saw her in there she was going
saying that
I didn't see that she was delicious I'll
buy a house from her he doesn't go out
again - I'll buy whatever where does she
sell what what area does she don't tell
Brian here oh la Hollywood Beverly Hills
area I'm not living in Hollywood in
Beverly Hills though you know what I
mean kids Jesus all right well
congratulations take care good I was
just happy to see you with the lady
toons you can play the piano I'm always
like not always but yeah Wow hot well
that was a bona fide smoke show really
she does she plays well huh you imagine
you mentioned have hairy arms or what
oh so what
yeah why new COS cat go all right see
cat and her men after the show can you
guys there - mm-hmm
[ __ ] it's cuz I was College if I make my
way through the crowd and I see cat and
she's with her man and I'm gonna go
what's up guys she's all you see Chin's
with a girl Mike really what'd she look
like cat goes who's right mm-hmm
very pretty girl comic store it's got
its whole situation doesn't it man was a
fun night
is it hotter for you guys or not nope
hot for you cuz you're gonna I'm real
freaking burn yeah bet your to try them
out chick target headaches no no hon
how's your tumor yeah it's better now do
you think you're having to go away but
it's better to kratom are you having
kratom withdrawals they're right there
so I can take it whenever so no
withdrawal is yet I'm a five and stop
I'm a fan of kratom myself dude daddy
took about four shots of whiskey last
night little kratom just good night or
kratom - oh yeah is it good whiskey wait
the best you take kratom sometimes Oh Oh
bye sometimes mean all the time oh
you're an addict - I didn't know not an
addict what the [ __ ] probably I do stand
now you're gonna be whiskey kratom and
anavar
please take anymore I'll get used to it
I'm slowly becoming the helsing I can
get you a whole jar for free really for
real it's legit you know it's from a
doctor that's one say it's legit yeah
well do do it I'll pay you for real yeah
get it and I'll take it okay it's tough
when people have DM me cuz I'm like Ida
you know who knows this is they send me
[ __ ] I got it estrogen pills or I got
steroids
I gotta get oh you're a seller dude I'm
gonna all broker the deal dude we're
like
we're like the we're like Mark Wahlberg
in the rock when they're selling right
but I want to shoot testosterone my ass
sibian eight and I'll take a Noir I'm
gonna be [ __ ] hey Jacques as they say
in France dude you know who might be on
the roid Oh
daliyah he's Jack didn't write that he's
not in the right but he's [ __ ] John
know what he's doing he's jazz but some
muscle he's really chris has a big frame
it's got a belly that Chris I went I
went we were in the hallway of it hey
Mike am I crazy you and I are the same
size and you guys we're definitely not
y'all know I feel like we're the same
size you're 100% dude click on here it's
about 180 no not that one makes me look
right there Chris plays 190 oh wait dude
he his upper buddies jazz his legs are
super skinny Bubba I don't care about
legs I give his shoulders yeah but look
at his legs
his midsection he still fit fairly thin
in comparison to you he's leaner well
you got 60 pounds on Bubba you see why
not I don't think I know
he's jacked man yeah be giant so you
know he just got big man yeah looks good
in it though you know I'm saying
looks good Tommy
it's disgusting I I can't do this
anymore like pose I said that to him and
then he posted it and I was like yeah I
was like every time I send something to
you you were crazy to post or see you
I'm like you gotta keep you posted yeah
but that's just an awful body plate or
no no I don't want to look alright I'm
just yeah holla saying that Chris is
Jack that he looks good man he's doing
that he's doing that movie role yeah
in Albuquerque like my JD but one is the
one I do a route of where I'd take my
breath away
I like the boxing scroll up it's watch
my hand up this way no I don't want to
watch him box please don't my hands are
good please just scroll let me scroll up
to the very top of it oh did you see the
one I posted bubble where I was like
there in bed do you see that one yeah
that's funny man
yeah what is that my and see that one
which one this one yeah
you probably feel fun oh
Timlin Oh chief you don't yet all right
I mean he looks hideous as an idea dude
okay we all do but that app people think
it's uh you know it's a Russian app they
think there's downloading our [ __ ] oh
yeah have you heard of this no yeah it's
incredible Bryan Callen did it but it
turned into a picture of a coffin
that's hilarious look at Whitney's
coming you look like every guy who deems
me are not Instagram look at that face
not is creepy oh yeah just father time
gets everyone man of all the times a
[ __ ] as we know what we look
like now dude you're off to San Fran I'm
off to San Fran Cobbs he comes me and
I'll be at Montreal the 26th I have a
show in Montreal at the comedy I just
for nothing just for laughs yeah so come
check me out I'm okay I'll be there I
can't wait
yeah I don't know there's decided to do
it oh that's cool man you'd be good um
I'm an indie dude I'm I get a little
break out to this road road road man
really need a break after indie that's
good yeah
sometimes you need a break but there you
get addicted to the road to know when
I'm not when I'm not on the road I miss
it
that's what back to back so she's
Cynthia Nika if you wanted to really
[ __ ] me up you could just tell me I
could never do the road again I'd have a
bad kid it'd be a disaster do Road daddy
woke up a little bit of a hangover the
Swazi oh damn a little drinking but when
you're a crazy mad act and then you do
whiskey as well what kind of whiskey do
I gots my life well Trey I'm Elijah 18
year old Elijah Craig 18 electrode you
Elijah what Elijah Craig 18 year old
whiskey that my boy Brian Cooley gave me
oh dude it'll knock your dick in the
dirt it's so smooth that my friends is
$300 bottle of something crazy yeah
doesn't mean it's so smooth my my buddy
who drinks whiskey goes dude I've been
thinking about the
whiskey do you have any more you wanted
to come over I'm like gonna be friends a
madhouse yeah well there it is for $35
now yeah but I'll buy it for $70 right
there you know no it's $298 look right
there right there see the 449 that's it
look at that that's actually four
hundred and forty nine dollars Jesus
Christ he spent a lot of money on me
holy [ __ ] look at that it's nice I'm not
familiar with Elijah four hundred and
fifty dollars but I mean the price no
bro no it's unbelievable dude it's
beautiful Buffalo Trace the day I die
that's better but it's better I'm not
kidding my buddy's a whiskey drinker he
sent me that well my whiskey whiskey
you don't know ease me J Szabo he's
drinks [ __ ] Japanese whiskeys well
this is every bit as good as any
Japanese whiskey I mean you don't drink
do you can't no very rarely never seen
you drinks you drag last night I
literally drink every time I go to
dinner with you guys now weird I don't
even see it would you drink last night
last night I got American Mule did your
man drink yeah he drank too we're not
really big on drinking you did get like
[ __ ] up no I get buzzed for like half
an hour and when I look at that right
now I just feel like sitting down and
having some having a glass of whiskey
I'd take a shot right now rap oh yeah
you you I like that you're right you're
a whiskey guy I never had a drink now
imma with you guy yeah you like your
whisk would have been a I'm telling you
know a little bit of trouble if the cops
pull me over like if you try if you
drink like I was in drunk and I was I
drunk a little tipsy I was in drunk and
I was in drunk I was just I di
let me think show started at eight
o'clock I had two shots at eight o'clock
you're fine I drove home at 1:00 a.m.
you're fine 206 I knew you're not yeah
no I wasn't drunk guys I thought about
yeah you think about it but if they
pulled me over I want to I definitely
pass the test but you know they can be
dicks I smell too cuz it's whiskey was
that fun by the way on my car's very
laughs but but I need you to try that
whiskey I need you to try Elijah we get
a ruin - it's tough for me to cheat on a
[ __ ] Buffalo Trace man will bring up
all the trace for a second I'm laughing
right now that's a 18 year old whiskey
don't talk to me about anything other
than that it's so smooth it's stupid
people go like this they drink they go
what you'll say
I don't know why that's a buffalo trace
verse but and then remember Buffalo
plays an awesome I trans I love lands
well there you go that's Buffalo Trace
bro so so because I'm a plantain sky
I'll go that ninety-ninth Buffalo Trace
for me I love I love Buffalo I love
plans that's my drink Buffalo Trace
but then there's Elijah Craig watch this
ready there's plans and then there's
Elijah yeah but how about you that
Buffalo Trace
ofc bro $1000 and it's a big boy yeah
that's amazing
it is so what do you drink which one you
drink
not that one they've never sent me that
one let me see I have I drink Blanton's
is my goat man but I know on the road
with my coach on the road I have one
request like I'm [ __ ] Mariah Carey
all I ask for is Buffalo Trace whiskey
well I love lambs but so Buffalo traces
out a lot of different ones are involved
Buffalo Trace owns all like makes up
Blanton's Buffalo trade a bunch of what
you know because they're the main
distillery yeah I thinking there yet
Kentucky well so so so you you see if
Elijah Craig falls under that because I
mean Blanton's is [ __ ] nice but I
think sighs Craig is so good but I'm
telling you I don't like the name so he
gonna hell but it's something you're
great at so good is it
I feel like go on and get you something
right now
but it's oh it will I mean I have the I
have them you know it's a if you bought
it above a bar it would be a hundred
dollars two hundred ollars a shot or
some crazy amount it's like Pappy Van
Winkle almost did some guy sent me a
picture within he had like 20 bottles of
Pappy Van Winkle I had some so once I
said the other day unbelievable where'd
you get it
I was with bas Rutten Frank Shamrock our
boy why don't always forget his name
Duane Ludwig nope
Bruce Lee spider Bruce Lee a famous
classic fighter Matt Coleman famous
fighter Mike Tyson 205 pound champ John
Joe eat this [ __ ] out of Senora del
Chuck without Jesus only
Oh hold on you were with blossom
structured Oh Frank Frank I'm a Pappy
Van Winkle it was great
why the [ __ ] were you with all those
guys - um I was in if I was invited to a
dinner and they were just there and I I
mean I saw I saw possum so hard I bet
well dinner they're like you how hard
he's your dick the entire dinner yeah I
was maitre around we played Red Rover
Red Rover and then did you see who had
the worst the and two fighters and well
boss and boss and a [ __ ] lawsuit I
sharp yeah that I have no does your OC
to you you don't see any I mean they're
just I don't his boss Amaro still doing
that podcast together I don't know I
don't think so I don't think some boss
is great here La Paz mystics loss is the
best
such a good guy so it's Frank they're
both great and Frank menge is uh Mauro
Brunello he's is me oh wow okay they're
super close yeah good guy man
interesting you have to deal with those
guys oh but that's where you drink Pappy
of anything yeah you know what it is
we're all the same age so when you got a
bunch of guys with [ __ ] in common
though they're well but but but but in a
way we have kids we're the same age
there's something about being the same
age with a bunch of men we are now
you're not talk about society or
anything you're just talking about life
like you're talking about you have a
boss's kid is it just graduate from the
high school it's this is interesting
stuff to me cuz I'm trying to gauge what
they're going through what I want to
expect with my kids what we end up doing
is talking about our kids almost always
it's so well you know I think Frankie's
got kids who are my kids age roughly and
so Chuck we're honest cause that way one
older boy who lives in Denver and then
two younger one yeah they're young and
your kids right yeah well they but no
but again we're talking about school and
where they go it's an it's so
interesting when when you get to a
certain age where the fighting mate it's
nothing to talk about it anymore cuz
what else you can talk about yeah yeah
yeah that chucks a great dude
yeah great guy yes all them are good
guys haven't seen behind heard from basa
forever I love him been married to the
same lady I she's not lost him ya know
Chuck she's a doll she's beautiful
mm-hmm how's her name
Hidy Hidy I thought Dwayne was with you
for some reason now I love Dwayne Dwayne
always comes to my shows in Denver oh
yeah of course yeah
are you uh when you're in San Fran is
tark gonna be out there with you or see
here he's not because he's honoring Mike
Lee in his fight this weekend against
the caliber Caleb Caleb Mike Lee's fight
it you know Mike Lee you know I'm a ops
I don't miss the the box I don't know
okay Mike's my weapon now should Notre
Dame and he's just a really good guy was
a football player right no Mike's been a
boxer forever all-american he's a boxer
but he's you know he's an all-american
boxers that exist I heard that he was an
all-american I was like okay well
there's the Olympic team so he's
fighting couch k LaPlante who's the
current champion um if you're on the
Olympic team I guess you could be
considered all-american oh he's on the
undercard of Pacquiao Thurman no there
you go that's a big card I actually
think there's a good chance Thurman
loses that fight really really why
terrible is a comeback fight man it's a
long layoff and Manny Pacquiao really
doesn't have off nights I mean how old
is Manny now is he 63 or 64 speaking of
anavar do you think Manny Pacquiao could
get us some uh you know it's only 40 it
looks amazing it's not young in boxing I
know you know what man Manny's a slight
favorite it was young for Bernard
Hopkins at 40 because here's the
exception yeah the exception I mean he's
no but Bernard Harvard's one overtime
man he's not especially at that lighter
weight class there's no exist just speed
Stephan well Bernard Hopkins did it no I
know I know
that's a good guy working at the grocery
store gun imma be an actor man he's 47
look at Morgan Freeman I know there's
Morgan hey man you're not Morgan Freeman
yeah there's only one Bernard Hopkins
well um especially if you're Manny
Pacquiao rely on just speed
yeah when are Hopkin was the mastermind
I remember who was it he said I can deal
with this power I just can't deal with
his speed it was a famous boxer was
fighting Manny
Oscar does that what it was yeah cuz I
can't deal with a speed Oscar De La Hoya
yeah
crazy speed yeah
[ __ ] man that weird kind of thing yeah
of course so so I've been so naive about
pro sports and you of course and I have
not been yeah you're in love but you're
near me I'm a bit of an infant yeah but
III since spoke to somebody who deals
with a lot of pro athletes and helps
them and and when you when you hear
about how they test say pro football
players pro hockey players it's very
easy to cheat on those tests yes it's a
base see you know don't be a dummy
that's it yeah do your share don't be a
dummy also you can tell selves oh yeah
eighty-five to ninety percent are doing
something I say that article where they
dive deep into remember I'm telling you
dude where they dive deep and
professional sports how these people are
on [ __ ] that's right but that's right
it's not but of course yeah I would
horse I'm Manny Pacquiao Jim I'm Bryan
Callen I'm gonna do anavar well you're
not but it'd be cool I did please do
anavar you'll do it if I give you some
if you get if you get it I'll do it okay
I want you on steroids
hey ma'am sorry look at him look at that
[ __ ] killer Jesus
I like the Manny before you get all
religious and he was like hooking up
with strippers and [ __ ] prostitutes
and like being out late at night and
gambling oh you you think religion saved
him from that you think religion has
changed him I guarantee no it has he's
like he's just a different dude no he's
not a killer anymore
yeah he's older Marquez well that's true
too he's older kids yeah who doesn't
like Manny Pacquiao I was at that fight
with who he beat him up man I remember
watching it you know Freddie was going
you know what's Freddie was saying put
him out you know what man he said I
don't want to hurt him I know well I
watch this great interview with Dan
Patrick and Manny Pacquiao oh I'm sorry
I'm Freddie Roach dan Patrick in Freddie
Roach and they asked him they go what
changed in what was the biggest change
in Manny Pacquiao and he goes when he
got knocked out by Marquez the he was
just different
yeah the killer instinct was just
completely going to sleep yeah well yeah
one of the worst night hits of all time
but he goes because he never really
suffered a loss like that and to get a
knockout you take some risk II made a
huge mistake right stepping inside his
left foot and so you got hit with this
straight right because he's never like
helped that had to deal with that he was
once that happened yeah when he came
back from training ditch the killer
instinct was gone because like oh well I
don't want do that again I don't want to
hurt people because I got hurt and he
I'm just gonna went off skill now I
don't wanna hurt anybody
Wow it's very strange man I haven't been
remotely in the same [ __ ] that was
the craziest I got in a back out but
when you do get knocked I like oh no I
don't want to do that anymore like don't
try but it's not it's not gunshot you
don't fight reckless in him right like
that's what happens GSP you'd want to do
it happened to you having at GSP
GSP got knocked out and never fought the
same again he just because you go oh
that's the consequence if you don't know
the ignorance is bliss and once it
happened to go oh dude [ __ ] that Emma
makes a little for me like for my little
bit from Waldo of fighting yet so you go
but it's true I got the first time I got
knocked out like I got kicked in the
[ __ ] head knocked out I just heard a
loud pop went down and from for a year
after I was I was you know what I would
do and I would never create distance I
I'd run in and just stop like trying to
stop something cuz I couldn't be on the
end of those punch it made me gunshot
and actually I was never I was never I
was like oh this is what like fighting
is with guys in me every time I go to
the [ __ ] studio I'd be nervous
getting knocked out is the worst it's
the worst and if it's your job holy [ __ ]
practice is like you know you the way
you guys spar is stupid then back in the
day shall I'm surprised you didn't get
I'm surprised you didn't get gun-shy
after sparring with Shane Carwin Soph I
never got knocked out yeah yeah was the
first time you got knocked out right
right right yep but then I just chalked
up as a fluke cuz hit me behind the ear
so I cast that about to deal with that
and then and Nogueira Nogueira was the
one was a gaff [ __ ] and then I came
not even really gun-shy cuz the cars
just being stupid I thought Roth well
then two knockouts back back am I then
might then I was like nope you were
beating his [ __ ] ass too yeah then I
was like nope no more of that I don't
feel that anymore so that way I went
straight to grass and wrestling yes yes
like now I'll just double leg you house
like why would I do this it's been CEO
Ben Askren returns
I'm sure depends on would imagine that
again you can you can whether one right
it's it's well it's just you bents I
mean that's such it it's I hate what
people call it lucky but it's just you
know it is the perfect storm where he
got knocked out he's undefeated grappler
and then that [ __ ] happens so you can
just be that that's never gonna happen
to pan again as long as he lives that's
never gonna happen again
Janson banking knocked up by flying me
in the opening bell it's not good yeah
so he's gonna be fine
look at that Moz balls a huge start out
as well he should be crazy why because
he beat Darren till cowboy Cerrone
stopped all of them and now I like it
when guys gonna fight that long and they
finally get their do yeah at Harrison
Justine I'm just taking a long [ __ ]
time to squirrel that horn rose wow
that's a long time that's pretty painful
to it painful and that guys not losing
this hair god he does not give a [ __ ]
my favorite the beginning of that fight
where he looks at him in smiles and puts
his hands behind his back yeah they
hated each other I think he was right he
goes oh so it's you can say anything you
want after this before the fight and
then when I knock you out a little
showboating that that's not allowed
people get upset really okay look at
that
yeah that's great he just takes it so
personally [ __ ] great we had some kind
of engine yes we do
look man you know something you and I
were super stylish huh I mean you wear
you wear vests with the sleeves get off
the sleeves cut off you know what they
they call this style what's that about
AC Slater is that what they call it yep
you know what they call yours why ma'am
stupid no I say that dude no you can
Isles mine's youthful Knives youthful
mine school
my schoolboy with a ball okay because
this is an adorable shirt and when
people see this shirt they go this
adorable now okay but here's the thing
you can get help me I can get you a
personal stylist there right now the
money for that you don't dude it's not
that expensive I'm talking about stitch
picks it's an online personal styling
service that delivers your favorite
clothing brands right to your doorstep
yeah can't you choose between life's
like stylish casual gamma Morty whatever
you want to do you want to look good
they got different styles go to Stix
Fitch comm slash spiders stick sacred
with sticks sticks stitch fix stitch fix
stitch fix stitch fix and through the
you can sensory tests probably not but
go to that and go to sticks week.com
hist a quick stitch fix 6h fix dot-com
slash fighter and it's a few questions
and then it shows up at your no we're
men required either you only pay what
you keep shipping exchanges returns are
always free plus the $20 styling fee is
automatically applied towards anything
you keep in your box you never have to
think about Stour looking good again get
you some hit on Brian what is it called
stitch fix yep yep get an extra 25% off
when you keep everything in your box
that's stitch fix comp slash buyer
stitch fix first one so a Texas woman is
facing two to twenty years in prison
because she lived with her mother's dead
corpse for two years it was reported by
the coroner that her mother suffered a
fall from the stairs and she died a
couple days later because her daughter
just left her there and let her die she
eventually moved her mother into one of
the rooms within her home and the woman
in her at the time under the age 15 year
old daughter was living in the house I'm
holed up
so she this this let her mom fell down
the stairs yeah in 2016 and wish you
didn't like shoes I can't I need help
yeah she was alive she died yes oh wow
that's what the woman did wow that's
terrible
she's like walk around her it didn't
specify but it seemed like she just kind
of like when about her day but
she's going I think she's going to jail
for her child she had a fifteen-year-old
right yeah cuz it's considered a
reckless endangerment of a minor Wow
because you left the child in there with
it with a dead body because she they're
saying that it would of had traumatized
the daughter to see one like her
grandmother just on the floor dot slowly
dying throughout the days and then also
seeing I didn't say anything but also
like you gotta check the mom's mental
state her mom dies and she's like
doesn't the body smell how did she get
because they said that there was a
terrible odor when they enter the home
wow that's a really weird situation let
me see that woman Victoria the mother
was 71 years old yeah yeah body smell
like [ __ ] I get a friend who works
doesn't look like she looks like a
corpse herself I'm sorry to say I I get
a friend it works with the California
Highway Patrol and they found you know
like on the underpass of Highways yeah
bums can its Hollow right so these
things can go through so you can knock
it out and there's like a hollow [ __ ]
cave of like cement
so bums will live in there I guess this
bum whatever like set a fire or
something and the smoke had no way to
get out so he died they don't know if
it's drug or door doors closed or that
so three days went by
you know how they found out that
someone's dead under there even outside
the smell of the dead body yeah like for
you walk Mike it smells like [ __ ]
there's a dead body okay I thought I
found it decomposed so you gotta imagine
inside a hot house you know they don't
have AC so in this hot-ass house I bet
it smelled like pure talkin look at her
look at her she looks yes she's good she
doesn't look healthy
no she's spots all over there's a crazy
person God these people are just crazy
you know there's obviously something
very wrong how's the 15 year old not say
anything that well child but I said a
fifteen-year-old like help you out drama
she's she's born into something yeah
she's my mentor this woman did to her
she's probably not well how did you not
help your granny like when they're
walking Mike she's like come on
it's all sickness it's all it's all
sickness and how the grandma not army
crawl out the door there's so many
questions so many questions buddy
a lot of questions when you're a cop you
deal with this [ __ ] could never be a cup
when you're a cop it's [ __ ] my friend's
bad situation but some guy I know his
mother was just murdered
they his next-door neighbors they've had
made news in Miami next-door neighbor's
20-something year old kids follow my
friend into his house and think he's got
cash mom comes out what's going on it's
2:00 in the morning
they sit her on a couch ask for money
they don't have any money they shoot her
dead and they shoot him in the back and
he's in the hospital right now
and cops deal with these guys now
they're looking for the kids and and the
kids were the neighbors and he knows
them and now they're on the run but this
is what as a code yeah that's gonna work
out this is what you do on the run
because they can you deal with these
[ __ ] scumbags or they're just like what
else he get so the CEO of the
e-cigarette jewel issued an apology to
parent saying that he's gonna go out of
his way to one he took down all the
social media accounts for jewel and he's
not gonna advertise geared towards
children anymore okay after he made all
his millions yeah he's saying that he
feels terrible because he himself has a
16 year old child and he can empathize
with parents who sees that their kids
are using his products he says that it
wasn't meant for kids but he can see why
with advertisements that they use with
like young 20 year olds using the jewel
products how and how easily to stick
here right I would assume he's that
they've bet jewels got bought out I'm
not actually made it is is vaping is
vaping considered as bad that was
cigarettes do we now bring it up chin
it's it's not good it's definitely not
good it's also really early for people
to find like a good study on it but it
doesn't seem like it's leading to great
places because you can control how much
nicotine you put into your ellic and a
lot of kids are using liquids with a lot
of nicotine in it and just running
through them but it is less harmful than
smoking so I would
you know they heat the nicotine I mean
that's you know yeah you can't no don't
say it's less harmful because you read a
[ __ ] blog but well but it is that
because when I set my tracker opposite
I've heard exact opposite from people
that are in the vape business but when
you when you when you heat the tobacco I
think you get more chemicals right so
you're inhaling the smoke and all the
chemicals whereas vape is actually this
is such bro sighs no it's not
I've read about it me too but it's not
anybody here mpany and we actually have
to sit down with okay but the board here
it's saying that it's kind of also
saying it so I'm not the one article
know there's a articles for and yeah
it's no one really it's like both we
don't know but I don't know I'm I'm
telling you they don't know but like
legit businesses are like no no no
because they're gonna be in trouble
yeah cuz some people who on the other
side of it say it's as bad as smoking
entire pack of cigarettes a day really
yes and some go well no because the
filter system is different but there
hasn't been a long extensive research on
it I mean now that one's good yeah
neither one's good we know nicotine's
not good for you though it's less that
it's the apparently the all the other
chemicals that come with it it's huge
though cuz you gotta figure the heavy
metals net called 10 lead which but you
gotta figure that the tobacco industry
went I people like their hip to
cigarettes no one's really smoking
cigarettes specially Millennials it's
almost completely gone we have come up
with something so they came up with this
and they're not exactly the best people
the tobacco but see here's easier as
biggest threat to public health may be
this the increased popularity of vaping
may renormalize smoking which is decline
for years Wow
smoke is still a leading preventable
cause of death that's responsible for
four hundred and eighty thousand
Americans yeah check this out vaping is
the most common form of tobacco use by
kids and teens I see it everywhere
you've seen everywhere you know and they
mark it to teens with the with the the
delicious flavors so you walk by it
smells fantastic
hmm yeah but I see I see it on both
sides
no I'm telling I think you know guys who
they don't know that [ __ ] who the the
big companies aren't they're not gonna
[ __ ] with it the big words are too
because I don't know they're gonna get
sued well they they know that this is
just if you're on the wrong side of
things you'd be fun mm-hmm what we don't
but we know for sure is it's not helpful
I was gonna say yeah tapings not good
for you whether it's less bad for you
than cigarettes is yeah it's still not
good for you it's fun and when we talk
about vaping up people Dean what about
when you won't get vaping is what do you
when you what about vaping weed versus
smoking weed Sam issue we don't know how
would assume say miss you man
I don't I don't smoke it anyway you know
I don't do anything no I just do CBD CBD
oil do you do is non psychoactive I
don't see I thought you smoked weed in
the war that night now never mind what I
just do CBD oil good get because they
relaxed me without yeah I don't know I
don't I I doesn't it gets in the videos
non psychoactive don't you think it gets
in the way you work like if I'm high if
I smoke weed tonight
even at night I wake up the next day a
little cloudy I'm not as sharp hmm sharp
personally people who when I see young
people and I look we can be good for
certain people when I see young people
who are trying to get somewhere in there
smoking weed all the time during the day
I I don't care what anybody says I don't
think that's a good I don't think that's
gonna be very good for your progress
sometimes people suffer from anxiety and
it can help them but I just feel like
overall average if I had them you know I
I think if you're if you're going for
something and you want to be successful
smoking weed in the morning it's wealth
when we during the day probably not it's
not gonna be helpful to you I don't care
what anybody says what do you think I
don't know it depends if you need if you
don't know I don't know yeah I would say
not to but some people were you talking
about dude the only way I get by yeah
some people that's see how we can get by
you know but yeah in general I would say
it's smoking anything so I can be good
yeah whether it's vape we eat cigarettes
now a little Elijah
18 euro okay if you want to do a couple
shots
some people said but actually you know
liquor kills more people than cigarettes
are [ __ ] weak yeah yeah Matt was
judging last night it's way worse free
than babe how about this with my buddy
my buddy goes to the doctor he's older
they look in his mouth daily you might
have throat or mouth cancer and because
I don't smoke and they go yeah but do
you drink he goes every day he goes
drinking if freaky yeah I'm he's always
drinking but the point is that the point
is is that alcohol actually is the
culprit they look at when you have mouth
I'll do that close it's so terrible for
you it's bad bladder cancer all those
weird cancers first thing they do is
they go do you smoke
I'm 52 and I go no the guy we're not
gonna really it's almost never with
unless you like smoking yeah if you
smoke they test you for bladder cancer
all kinds of weird [ __ ] you're getting
you're so when you smoke you actually
are more likely get other cancers a lot
of times according to my doctor then
lung cancer so when you're younger who's
never smoked you're gonna get you're
gonna get they'll check you for this
it's very common to get other cancers
and lung cancer I thought lung cancer
was the number one thing you get no no
you're more likely to get these other
weird things that matter the answer
stuff like that yeah what else yet Jun I
think that's what I was told anyway
possibly so this 20 year old man helped
save his nieces and nephews after the
home that he shares with his older
sister was burning down so he ran
outside when the second story got caught
on fire the fire actually started in the
house they don't know why and what
happened exactly
but the whole family was asleep they
woke up when they smelled the smoke the
mom stayed upstairs with the three kids
to help throw them out and he ran
through the fire downstairs to help
catch the children the two boys were
able to jump out of the window and he
caught them but the mom ended up falling
before he was she was able to help the
niece get down the niece was too scared
to jump so he ran back into the house
grabbed her took his shirt off wrapped
it around her and ran back downstairs
with her and he suffered a lot of
terrible burns
[ __ ] and what does as a man yeah he's
a young uncle
yeah he's 20 arms and back Derek bird
wants you to know how special his niece
Mercedes Wow home he jumped into action
helping the kids mother
Caleb his sister okay one kid that said
I ran downstairs even though that Brent
started go see the kids
Junior and I thought baby boy out the
window but eight-year-old Mercedes was
afraid to jump oh you heard that
dang well yeah he's a hero his
neighborhood is helping him out with the
cost of his medical bills as well as
donations for clothes and anything else
his family needs right now what a badass
right
that's insane he ran back in there yeah
hopefully he won't have to his stock
scarring won't be too bad
I know all right next one this is
awesome okay so something to lighten up
a teachers release Colombian man went
through an airport trying to smuggle
thirty four thousand dollars worth of
cocaine under his toupee so he taped the
cocaine to his head and that he got to
pay that was too big for his head and
try to walk through TSA with it it's the
worst week ever yeah I mean would I even
if he was at hiding stuff I do you I
take that off
what are you looks like a giant bird yes
a gent saw it was like huh there's
something kind of off I don't think this
is just a bad toupee so they ended up
searching his like touching his head and
they realized there's something under
and that's how he got caught he looks
real what I guess hatred coke how dumb
do you have to be to put that on your
[ __ ] you don't know that you look
ridiculous
and by the way toupees every time I see
an older man with a toupee you know my
mother with a serious face cuz where I
got him loose in my hair I think she
goes wear a wig what are you doing I'm
with your mom on that but not like this
you know like that won't look so bad but
how stupid does this guy have to be
obviously really think is gonna work out
obviously he's weighs risking 30 years
it also looks like you're hiding a giant
amount of cocaine underneath that toupee
without even like if you just show me a
picture like you always hiding something
under this but my brains extra big yeah
that's all so you could wore like long
hair could what hi there's so many
things hey rooster head what the [ __ ]
you doing God he looks so really kiss
things aren't going well for him it's
hope that's hilarious just on my head
nothing to see here see your own on the
other side see here I just have a growth
I would have been like it's a mole okay
I leave me out the tumor it's over there
two layers what else you got
remember that girl Brittany's the more
off the teacher the hotter
yeah she will she she got her sentencing
done and guess how many years she got
seven 20 years I think it's pretty crazy
right twenty years what a waste of
taxpayer money it's a long time it's
gonna be bad for her in jail that's
[ __ ] terrible yeah that's so stupid
yeah how much time to give her none yeah
it's just none I put on house arrest
yeah yeah I was like teach for free with
like summer school or some [ __ ] yeah
IG did is she really a criminal I mean
danger to society
I wouldn't say but she has to get some
time but I think 20 years it's just
crazy like they're still we could put
her on some sort of weird like she could
do a lot more stuff for society to help
Society than be in prison
lost murderers and [ __ ] Psychopaths
up not this lady who likes to bone kids
well that sounds weird I said out loud
so that the mother of the 11 years what
a peak come on the mother of the 11 year
old duck she asked to stand outside the
teacher asked him to stand outside while
the other 13 year old kid and her were
having sex
she was super pissed off at her too who
said who did the mother so the there's
an 11 year old kid that was asked by the
teacher
to watch the door to make sure no one
comes in while she's boning the 13 year
old student look man this is weird this
is a [ __ ] wackadoodle woman so I
gotta tell you gotta laugh it oh no
they're in sixth grade I can't imagine
[ __ ] yeah you know if a teacher did
that I'd be like hey aster kid just to
watch out yeah yeah you got your I won't
be living look this person was having
it's doing look something's wrong with
this person
anything else they're crazy this is a
crazy / I agree she has some [ __ ] you
know you're gonna get caught how are you
doing at some horrible issues 20s in
prison 20 does sound 20 years in prison
I would say this person needs deep
psychological counseling the under house
arrest
yeah or something like that I should
Rama's who's gonna take care of her but
is she gonna get better in prison now
this are these these cravings gonna go
away for the 13 year olds in prison no
that doesn't solve anything but I mean
you're also do it again she's got other
kids involved in this she's texting with
them this is somebody who is not in
their right mind not a twisted monster
this is a crazy person this is um you
know what I'm saying like you're
cheating it out in ways that of course
are gonna put you to the face forty
years now here's with this where it's
kind of weird
imagine if there's a male teacher with a
female I'd like a lock them of course
you know it because it's penetration
though there's a big difference I mean
in the sense that there's a physical
like if you talk about 13-year and like
dude are you traumatize like no I'm
awesome
yeah I was busting nuts dude and my
sixth grade teacher yeah I mean I don't
know but you know the same time at 14 I
would have I would have been very happy
yeah I'm like what lock doors for what
me at all so that's me why are we
locking you up you take away my [ __ ]
for I had sex with a you know well I'm
almost sex but fool around with this
like a woman who was 20 and I was
fantastic or 18 are you traumatized oh
well the time at this thirty knows me
traumatized I don't know if she was like
bullying I'm like suck these tits
and he's like I wanna like that's
different this sounds like he was into
it
look 13 real dialed 13 has a true child
though when you see 13 euro 100% you
know no I hear you
so I'm saying I know person when I was
in sixth grade the hot teacher asked me
to bless some nice kids an eighth grader
this kids not sixth grade eighth grade
even better dude so eighth grade you
however the sixth grader was asked to
watch the don't see that's a little
weird
well the six names me fine too all right
did you see anything there's something
said about sexualizing a child though
that can't be allowed again I I'm with
you and I hear you and this is [ __ ] up
however when I was in eighth grade if I
[ __ ] a hot teacher
trust me I'd be just fine these days
yeah you're not saying yeah well you're
a guy talking about a girl and I do it I
think there's a double standard but I
agree with that but that's what's going
on here I know it's a double standard if
it now feels a million now women are way
less so if you asked women about this
their mothers that day I would walk
right by us and go you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking really mattered
I think so it's a buddy 99% of the
world's not agreeing with this well the
dudes are well the dudes but it's isn't
it funny how women are very unforgiving
men with women and men you know it's
like yeah Oh women are you'd say cut her
head off guys are the guys are like yeah
you know what do you think that she's
gonna get [ __ ] up in prison
for touch and yes do you know how many
mothers grandmothers and aunts would
love to get their hands on her how are
you right like with you can she go to
prison for 20 like you have a problem
that a 20 year old what she's 20 right
28 or something like 28 or she's 20 had
sex with the 8th grader I do I do have I
do think that she's sick but at the same
time I feel like if a man was gonna get
20 years she should get 20 years for the
same crime honestly there you go you
think it's the same I mean you still
touched a kid I see where you're gonna
wear you're getting at but I don't know
I think it's hard cuz I have a youngest
but this way let's put this right just
like if she had sex with the 13 year old
boy I think the difference is this the
13 year old I've done that for enough
teachers that the skid there no that's
their husband here here's how I think we
can talk about it the 13 year old had to
get to a point where he was sexually
aroused right like we're an old man
whereas a girl you
you know that's not how it is Right
girls different girls zero it is so so
so so there than anyway but I don't know
but she was married to this guy right
she was married it is a very bizarre
thing I think this person is not in her
right mind oh me oh my god 13 oh boy I
feel like he's gonna be okay for me I
just think you're talking about a crazy
person hundred percent crazy needs to be
in deep psychiatric counseling and I was
okay in my wing I don't get any
satisfaction about her going to jail if
it's a man who didn't put him in jail
why because I don't bring him out but
the main kill to a child yeah and you
can overpower those gals in it like that
yes she's I can overpower this eighth
grader there are a lot of different
tried to arm-wrestle me an eighth good
beat the [ __ ] yeah there's violence
there are different factors here well
yeah yeah tough 20 years men yeah well
chef you gotta know that well show you
how but she's a seven by the way of
course it is said right you go like this
of course you do
yeah you gotta do something right we
can't have you [ __ ] kids we just
can't wait piss so hard did go for let's
do this what else we got kids that's on
the other side of the spectrum
remember our Abel Trujillo yes yes see
he was party there's he he's accused of
sexual exploitation of a child well it's
kind of confusing so when I was reading
the definition of it it's like he's sort
of he didn't touch anyone or anything
but he's he has like some pornographic
materials that would that involve minors
and he's also selling it or distributed
to minors so he has picture of like
teenagers and he was giving it to other
teenagers got yes and then also just him
possessing it also it's illegal
oh this is in Colorado - mmm-hmm so the
most you could get though is 18 months
that's it mmm homegirl got 20 years yeah
he's not touching anybody
yeah so he's arrested well when you get
arrested they have a case dude he's
violent I mean Team Russia had allotted
like like they have evidence and he
before he pleaded guilty to two
different domestic violence cases and
then he was also part of UFC while they
knew that seems like a smart guy Jesus
Christ man I don't know what to say
about that yeah dumbass
all right John Krasinski he said he is
filming a sequel to quiet place yes and
that's one picture from the set okay and
then this is another one it's so good
what a career like just curveball going
from being the guy in the office where
he's like that comedian actor yeah he's
probably cookie looking guy he's simple
and then gets jacked he's a Navy SEAL in
that one move what's called the 13th
hour yeah he's so good in that and then
writes directs put his what puts his
wife in the same the quiet place I'm yep
Emily blonde she was so good or not that
was a great movie man wow that movie so
good it's ridiculous art is such a good
wait that's amazing
sweet did you guys see this video so I
saw it on nature's medal and on Mike's
wyx Instagram it's a elephant rushing a
safari vehicle
they go backwards almost happened to me
really oh yeah well not like this yes
almost public for real this is very
common man and they can they can
overturn that thing easily okay
damn that elven spits angry around I was
impressed by the driver to that drivers
nice was it going backwards not getting
[ __ ] up look at the [ __ ] [ __ ]
camera
how stupid are humans well let me record
this for Instagram we're gonna lose that
power line that thing over dude it'll
turn it over and I was it is so nice
it's so scary man and they can turn that
truck over no problem I wasn't exactly
that truck wouldn't when this giant
elephant was doing this to us not
hitting it but coming at us and and mock
charging and the guy said stay very
still just stay very still and and my
daughter was crying and it was off it
was [ __ ] scary should I show you the
video of it yeah it's [ __ ] definitely
not like that but I well we had nowhere
to go
yeah we couldn't get out in trouble if
that thing was that aggressive yeah did
you guys know and it's usually young
bulls and the reason that there was a
female on heat yep you know I don't do
do safaris I'm all yes I don't know why
so the guy who was there who was our
driver had had it happen to him and he
the guy he was with had to be airlifted
out cuz he had his [ __ ] legs broken
the whole thing was the disaster I'll
say this about when an elephant's
charging and whenever you're on safari
and you should go on so I would never go
and always carry a [ __ ] small mouse
and to secure though yeah and so is that
true is that true that's absolutely not
absolutely not but Thank You gracias
loony to an elephant's not afraid of a
tiny mouse but thank you for asking why
did they make us ready is not even
afraid of a lion sir I know but thank
you for that how did how did that become
like that was cartoon that was a cartoon
and
Mythbusters elephant versus mouth but
the elephant's fear has more to do with
the Elmo surprise than the mouth
theories around the Elven sir
afraid of mice because they're tiny
creatures nibble on the feet all they
nibble on their feet so they you know
what happened
one Mouse like only nibble under this
[ __ ] elephant's need he went whoa oh
dude he's terrified oh it's like no I'm
not what are you talking about in them
that's why though I always carry a
number of mice and I let them all go
another do you have a lot of mice
they're scared of mice ghetto [ __ ]
thick rat I get a bunch of rats yeah at
least them I can conjure rats I don't
know if you know that I conjure them
interested and I release them and then
that's what happened in Africa Africa
and they all ran away
that's so yeah cuz the cartoons started
that elephants were scared of mice me
ethically yeah just this illness it
could be you see an elephant jumping up
on a stool when there's a mouse what
else you get you all must says that
they're his neuro-link company I just
saw this Kenneth Gary yeah they're
they've been testing microchips in
brains and they test it on chimps and
they actually worked like they were able
to control computers with their minds
well he was saying by 2020 he's gonna be
able to connect humans yeah to computers
I have a skeptical hippo eyes but maybe
it's true what do I know
yeah it's scary but that's the way we're
headed this is what he's what he wants
to do is to treat brain disorders like
Alzheimer's or incidence yeah
and then eventually become AI or did you
see now Tiger twined Elon Musk what's
that yeah it's very funny
wait go out for a second just how about
a amber port where it's a machete attack
what happened I don't know who that is
from team if you watch T mom she's like
the main team she was she's everywhere I
don't know she's had she's been she went
to prison for domestic violence yeah and
then she did like I don't know like a
year and a half got out right so that
there's big talk to that and then now
apparently straight attacking her new
man with a machete in front of the kids
they're all making headlines right
although the cast members for sure we
haven't talked about Peter Whitaker dead
it hit by a porn Elwood oh yeah he's
gone peewee yeah sweepy sweepy sweepy I
mean okay we're gonna go sleepy it's
very sad
yeah
- mark Kelly's sex slaves are still in
his condo interesting he's [ __ ] huh
he's definitely messed up for sure what
else we get how do we just end on this
one we were reading this today this Iowa
agency director he has this huge
fascination with Tupac Shakur so all of
his employees he would just continue to
email stuff about Tupac Shakur sings you
know like quotes and stuff like that he
would have parties he would have two
pucks before Tupac Shakur Fridays it's
guys awesome you want to look if he was
- it looks like he got so he had to
resign him he's a fat white guy that's
him
[ __ ] yeah oh I wish she was my dad he
seems cool so all he would do is send
them to pocket in the month stop yeah
constantly they're saying that's not
exactly why he got resigned but it
happened be my most immediately
afterwards - you think why because Jerry
Foxx joven 66 and won't stop some people
lyrics of Tupac Shakur he's crazy
over 350 so but he would he would just
let's see the email which featured in
the image of a smiling Shakur - mark hit
him up mark the hit him up rappers
birthday that weekend by listing one of
his songs he also noted the occasion
that his 2 year energy is director thank
the staff for the work weird ok it's
just funny good for him good POC Friday
it's pretty fly for a white guy dude
pretty fly well yeah
shoutout to that guy yeah just a little
crazy a little crazy about - do you
think that what Trump said was racist
about back to your countries yeah he
didn't say go back to your countries go
back to the way siren infested riche did
you come from meaning what's he talking
about their districts no I don't think
so and they're all minorities no I know
but yeah
you're not saying though is that all
fresh air yeah fun if he meant their
districts are you mean their countries
or countries for sure we said what's not
from him no I don't think the press
countries but he said places so I feel
like the press is misquoting him and I
don't know if it was racist is that
racist or is that go back here
yeah but how is that racist that might
be like your again I don't think
I'm racist but I think it but that's all
just all involved just for the liberal
press keeps saying is that he was racist
well they have nothing else to talk
about
right but the way they're framing it
feels like it's just just tell me what
you think um I just a little I don't
want my president talking like that
definitely sloppy I crazy at racist no
go back and it's very even totally it's
very my reckless go back yeah go back
for a second said weird that that was
already says go back and help fix the
totally broken and crime-infested places
from which they came so hold on so go
back and help fix the totally broken and
crime-infested places from which they
came does that mean incredibly states
women of color all came from other
countries there but he said places so is
he talking about their districts because
she's from the Bronx she's the district
the Bronx
the other ones from Michigan I think
Detroit these are not places that are
doing that well and he's not good with
words
mm-hm I don't know he's not good with
the words just sloppy with it like yeah
if he's talking about the the districts
they represent you think it what do you
worry about worry about your shaky and
figure that out
you say I'm gonna come at Magog you
can't figure your own area he's talking
about the places these congressmen yeah
I don't think he's telling the one who's
right from sedan or whatever be like go
back there
I think he's literally talking about the
districts that they represent it's not
racist it's just slop but did he say
country cuz it says yeah Trump saying
then you go back to the country's pretty
much ammonia but can I see that's what
Jim brought up for you be there it is
and visually tell people United States
the greatest most powerful nation on
earth arguments rerun why don't they go
back and help fix the totally broken and
crime offense places from which they
came then come back and show us how yeah
there's nothing about countries though
yeah but he is so he said where they
came from because look vicious he's
telling people in the United States the
greatest must be no nation on earth are
hologram is run why don't they go back
and how
fix the totally broken and
crime-infested places from which they
came
yes I'll say she told him come out and
show us how and tell the people the
United States and then come back and
tell I get it I get it yeah I get it
it's like you don't your president
talking like that yeah hey hey dummy
he's there from the United States well
all for a minute don't [ __ ] impulsive
man yeah I get it
it's yeah I didn't now I now I get it
yeah well yeah it's in on that dude here
meet San Fran be almost sold out buddy
Cobb ya Cobbs the 19th 20th and then
I'll be like this Friday Saturday that's
this Friday Saturday I'm at Cobbs -
shows Friday to Saturday get your
tickets they're going fast and then
mohei on the 26th I'm at Just for Laughs
comedy festivals so come see me there
get your tickets get you see this week
I'm in Indy this Thursday Friday
Saturday that is the 18th through the
20th Indy helium and he gets yo tickets
after that August 1st through the 3rd
I'm in Nashville those tickets almost
sold out Nashville at Zanies all my
favorite spots then I'm in Portland
Portland helium that is August 15th
through the 17th and then just added I
think they got the date up there yep and
the link Houston just hit the charts
Houston give me toasty in September
September 20 through the 21st then I end
in my hometown Denver Colorado at Comedy
Works get your tickets now in DC of this
Thursday Friday Saturday tea fat cake on
four tickets for Brian and myself we
also just dropped new skeptical hippo
t-shirts on TV back a calm and a few
other tasty treats for that ass anything
else dude hey buddy you love Trump is
the part of the kid
we're out